but i remember just before i fell asleep
i checked the view cannon was on like 3
000 views and at the time i was like
well that seems high but okay i'll just
sleep on it and i got it the next day
and it was on 300 000. and then i
checked my kind of inbox and it was
filled with like uh cnn news wants to
talk to you um bbc news good morning
america like all these places wanted
wanted a piece of me and i just i
couldn't understand what was happening
it was a mindset shift of like whoa this
youtube thing like this potential of
virality it suddenly became like quite
real hey friends welcome back to the
deep dive in this episode i speak to
aaron maney who is europe's biggest tech
youtuber also known as mr who's the boss
his channel has over 9 million
subscribers and he's an absolute
inspiration in the episode we talk about
aaron's early life and how he would have
these dreams of being a youtuber when he
was young and at school and we talked
about his journey of going full time on
making silly internet videos on youtube
rather than doing a traditional
prestigious consulting career at pwc we
talk a bit about his life as an
influencer and what it's actually like
to be europe's biggest tech influencer
and all the ridiculously cool things
that he gets invited to do and we also
talk a little bit about the idea of
hedonic adaptation there is a point when
you start to think like what am i
chasing here like how is my life
different when i'm at 10 million versus
9 million or nine million versus one
million you know at a certain point
you're making a living it's your
business you're comfortable
and so
you you have to kind of separate
yourself from that you can't tie
yourself
to a number that you have no control
over i've been following aaron's channel
for absolutely ages now and it was such
a an honor and joy and inspiration to be
able to speak to him i'm i'm really
gushing like i'm a real fanboy here
because i am and it was great it's also
like really interesting just how he how
much effort goes into the magic that is
his youtube channel and you'll see for
later on in the episode i'm just
absolutely flabbergasted as to just the
insane amount of effort he puts into it
and hopefully that'll come through in
the episode as well so yeah grab a cup
of tea and i hope you enjoy this
conversation with me and mister who's
the boss let's go all right aaron
welcome to the podcast how are you doing
i'm very good it's good to be here yeah
it's uh it's it's nice seeing you in the
flesh we've spoken like twice two three
times on the phone before so
it's it's weird seeing you here i was
actually just in in the toilet earlier
today and i was watching your your pixel
versus iphone camera comparison
so yeah i feel like i'm getting the full
real life experience satisfactory toilet
video yes yeah it was it was quite it it
was quite satisfying
like like the b-roll you have like the
little like sound sound design when you
show a photo all the photos of yourself
all the selfies at different angles
different like focal lengths i have
actually saw very well done
i feel like a dj more and more every day
because i'm spending more and more of my
time looking at sound and how it syncs
with the video yeah cause actually i'm
glad you mentioned it yeah i thought the
sound design was very well done i was i
was going to post a message to our
editor on slack and be like can we do
more sound stuff because it's just like
like all the little subtleties like
where the beat drops yeah it's it's it's
very well done um firstly happy birthday
thank you
you've just turned 26. yeah um
um so you know you're like
absolutely huge you've got like 10
million followers across across the
social media platforms
what would your like school high school
self secondary school self
have said let's say say 10 years ago if
you'd known this is where you'd be at
26. so i actually i distinctly remember
a little meeting i had with a friend um
we were at school and we were looking at
other youtubers on the platform
and we were like dreaming of what it
would be like to have 10 000 followers
we would look at channels like that and
we're like oh my god i could do that and
this person has the audience that could
fill a stadium that's ridiculous because
when you're looking at numbers like 10
000 you can actually visualize it and
when you do visualize it it seems
enormous
um so
i don't know i think i would have
cried or had a fear if you talk i don't
know
so one thing i i found really
interesting about about your story and
you talked about this a little bit in
the podcast with stephen and a little
bit in your draw my life video is that
uh growing up you're you're a massive
nerd shall we say i'm a nerd i'm still
in there
yeah um and and and you said that in in
primary school you ended up like playing
chess for england or something that's
very cool
and then in in secondary school things
things were a little bit a little bit
difficult i wonder if you can you can
talk a bit more about what that
experience was like yeah i think
i think more and more it's easy
to feel insecure in yourself
um i think for me youtube was like a
vehicle towards confidence
and i was almost lucky that i found it
and like
did it properly
but at school i had very little
reassurance in myself and like people
would constantly tell me like every
touch point i had with another person
was generally a negative one it's like
oh you're really nerdy oh you're really
lanky oh your skin is awful oh you need
to shave that beard of yours or if you
call it a beard
um so i just didn't have a very good
impression of myself
and then how did how did youtube fit
into this
so i think i was probably at my lowest
point when i started youtube and to be
honest even when i started it for the
first few years it wasn't a big part of
my life and i was quite embarrassed
about it and i wouldn't tell anyone
but i think there was like an internal
sense of like i am doing something that
other people aren't doing and that's
quite that's quite nice so was it a kind
of a way of
of
having that
that aspect having an aspect of your
identity that you could kind of point to
internally and say that yeah i'm doing
something cool was it was that the vibe
something like that yeah i mean i had no
idea that it could be a career or what
it would turn into but
yeah it felt it felt cool
i remember actually there was a point
when i showed my friend that i had a
channel with 5 000 subscribers and he
said no way that's not you
because at that point it was only in my
hands but i had to convince him i had to
be like look listen that's my voice now
hear my voice in person it's me
nice yeah wha what prompted you to start
start the channel so
my brother bought me my first smartphone
and uh
i think especially relative to my real
life at the time
this smartphone was like it was like a
guilty pleasure like i just fell in love
with that thing
and so like naturally just learned as
much as i could about it
and then one day i just thought
i've got enough info to share with
people so i just made this video on like
how to customize it just add themes make
it faster
and it just did better than i expected
and then i i kept going
but i literally i remember a point where
my life goal was to get that phone to
score a certain score in a benchmarking
app
okay that was just my purpose it wasn't
a good phone but i wanted it to be
better
and that kind of created a drive to
find out how to do that a lot of people
have this thing where where they get
super interested in something they go
deep on it but then it
i imagine like most people don't then go
a step beyond and think i'm going to
make a youtube video about this thing
what what was it about you can you can
you remember like that made that that
leap
i actually don't remember yeah i don't
remember i just i'm just very very very
grateful for whatever the trigger was
yeah um i'm assuming it was something to
do with the fact that i did watch other
youtubers and i think some part of me
just wanted to be like them
were you were you worried at all about
what people would think
when you started extremely okay
extremely yeah i mean like i was not a
confident person and i was very aware
that on camera i was not going to give a
good impression
um i it was strongly driven by my
passion for what i was covering i'll put
it that way
ouch on cam on camera than if people saw
your face that there yeah i didn't
reveal my face for a good few years i
think it was just hands
um and even then people were like your
voice is so irritating shut up
but yeah it was good
what were the kind of comments like in
those because
like when i started it was like i
started it was like 2017 i was i was
pretty old i was like 23. um and
it was all educational content where the
comments were just broadly like oh my
god thank you so much for helping me get
into uni kind of vibes but whenever i
see comments on tech videos in
particular it seems like it's a bit more
polarizing than whenever the tech
audience is quite
uh the tech audience is quite hard to
please
um so they're very educated uh but also
cynical bunch they can be amazing but
they will pick apart everything you say
yeah and you can never contradict
yourself you have to make sure you're
100 consistent and like you fact check
everything you say and so when you throw
that kind of pressure on like a 15 year
old who doesn't really know what they're
doing completely
uh you're gonna get things wrong and i
think i wasn't ready for people to
pounce on me in the way they did
but it's good that it happened because
you develop a thicker skin
how do people pounce on you
oh it's stuff like
uh you're doing this all wrong you idiot
or like
i mean there was there was racist stuff
there was like there was all sorts of
just like nasty comments i mean
technically there is truth hidden in
most of them and as long as you can kind
of scrape away the layers that you don't
like you can find it but
definitely abrasive comments or put it
that way
and did you start getting those from
from like day one or
i think especially on day one oh wow
because the videos are the worst i think
the better your videos get
generally speaking the more
the tone shifts to positivity yeah so
you're
so you're 15 not having a great time at
school socially and you decide to start
the youtube channel and on day one you
start getting hate
hate comments about it yeah my first
video did better than i thought it was
okay then i thought it would um and so
it hit like fifty thousand views which
is rare for a first year yeah it's also
like really good back then as well yeah
yeah especially good back then
so i wasn't ready for it yeah there was
definitely an influx of people
not none of them who subscribed because
the video was so bad
you know there were comments yeah
and so at that point
again if i if i imagine myself at 15
it's you know things that think that i'm
going great at school i put out a video
it gets
gets a bunch of hate comments it would
be very easy for me to just be like okay
i've tried this thing it's not working
let's i don't know try and become a
chess international masters i don't know
whatever um like really lean into the
nerd um what what was it do you think
that kept you going with the youtube
stuff we're gonna take a very quick
break to introduce our sponsor for this
episode and that is brilliant i've been
using brilliant for the last two plus
years they're a fantastic platform for
learning maths science and computer
science with engaging and interactive
online courses and the great thing about
brilliant is that they really teach
stuff from a very first principles based
approach it's almost like the way that
we were taught in places like oxford and
cambridge where you learn a concept and
then you apply the concept to an
interesting problem rather than just
being spoon-fed stuff like we initially
learned in school my favorite courses on
brilliant are the computer science ones
as some of you guys might know i was
torn between applying to medicine and
computer science i went for medicine in
the end but i always had an affinity to
computer science and taking the courses
on brilliant like their introduction to
algorithms and their introduction to
python really helped me get more of a
grasp of computer science than i've ever
had before it's also great for learning
how to code which is an incredibly
useful skill to have especially if you
want to start a business and i attribute
like 98 of my business success to the
fact that i learned how to code when i
was in secondary school so if you want
to check out the courses on math science
and computer science then head over to
brilliant.org forward slash deep dive
and the first 200 people to sign up with
that link will get 20 off the annual
premium subscription so thank you
brilliant for sponsoring this episode so
i think this is really important
actually
it is said a lot you have to really love
what you do so it's the fact that
i had all this tech in my house because
i'd been buying it anyway as i was
growing up and i was so passionate about
that tech that i just i was having fun
doing it
um so my my first two years was
basically me just kind of like roaming
around my house trying to find things i
already had using equipment i already
had and just filming it and just talking
i wasn't thinking about things like you
know watch time or retention or like you
know consumer insights it was very much
just a case of oh this is fun were you
trying to stick to like an upload
schedule or anything then or just i
didn't know what an upload schedule was
so
so you started the channel at 15 what
did things look like then on on the
channel kind of over the next few years
very kind of like bitty um
it wasn't that i wasn't trying to be
consistent but it's the fact that
oftentimes i just didn't have anything
to show or say it wasn't like i was
getting the latest samsungs or latest
apples or anything like that so when i
got something cool i talked about it um
but it also meant that like i was doing
videos at very strange times when most
people wouldn't have been like the day
before my a-level exams i was just sat
in the garden recording some earphones
that just came in and stuff like that
what was the growth like in those in
those early few years
nothing special yeah
and you just kept going but kept at it
because it was fun
yeah yeah pretty much okay at what point
did you start kind of taking it
seriously
so there was one big turning point um
and it happened part way through
university so it's probably like 20 i
think it's 2015.
and it was one video i uploaded just as
part of one of my you know many other
videos i uploaded i didn't think much of
it yeah and i fell asleep
but i remember just before i fell asleep
i checked the view cannon was on like 3
000 views and at the time i was like
well that seems high but okay i'll just
sleep on it and i got it the next day
and it was on 300 000. and then i
checked my kind of inbox and it was
filled with like uh cnn news wants to
talk to you um bbc news good morning
america like all these places wanted
wanted a piece of me and i just i
couldn't understand what was happening
um and it was getting like 80 000 views
an hour i just was not accustomed to
numbers like that
and it was basically a video on how to
turn your phone into like a hologram
so it just did really well i think it
was a combination of like clear tutorial
released at the right time it was like a
friday just before the weekend so it
became like this viral diy project i
guess
um
and even though like that one thing
didn't change my overall average view
count too much or didn't rocket my
channel into millions it was a mindset
shift of like whoa this youtube thing
like this potential of virality it
suddenly became like quite real
so what happened then
so yeah i still wasn't making enough
from it to like call it a job
immediately and just quit everything but
it was um
it was definitely a shift for me my
parents my family my friends like
everyone was all of a sudden like whoa
like some there's something there's
something here so i think i started
taking it more seriously
creating a rough schedule trying to
actually get stuff from brands like
things like that
so if i had to put one thing as like a
turning point it would be that
interesting so it sounds like a kind of
if you're if you're halfway through
university you would have been sort of
19-ish 1920 when that happened
yeah so you'd been doing youtube for
like five years four five years at that
point kind of just for fun yeah because
you enjoyed the process you enjoyed
reviewing the stuff because you were
into tech you were passionate about the
thing
and then
like all of that
it's like i i think this is fascinating
because there's always kind of this myth
of the overnight success
and when you see
you know i love looking at channels that
are huge now and looking at their older
videos and seeing oh wow you know like
how much has started and how you started
and all these like people who are
absolutely enormous
um i think now
speaking to a lot of people who are
starting youtube channels
the survivorship bias means that the
only channels they really see are the
big ones and it's hard to imagine that
you could be doing this thing for five
years before
any real traction and start starting to
take it seriously yeah and it's also
tough to see
what exactly led up to that moment so
before i posted that hologram video even
though in my head i'm like well what was
i prating around at with those 300
videos before that why did i need to
make those i should have just made this
from the start i needed to make every
one of those videos to learn the things
i needed to know to make the hologram
video did you end up going on like good
morning america and things like that
like
i took on a few of them there were a few
like local news channels that i did um
yeah
what was that experience like like being
on the news very
i felt a little out of place i'll put it
that way because i didn't know how to
like present still it was still like the
video itself it's not something i'm
proud of like from a production
standpoint yeah um i still wouldn't back
back how i came across in that video and
so you ended up sort of being
sort of i won't watch them again those
interviews
no fair enough okay so at that point you
started taking things more seriously
what
what was your kind of non-youtube life
looking like at the time i had a pretty
good time at uni um i was very
disciplined with my time because as i
started to take youtube seriously it's
like whoa okay so i'm at uni i've got to
have a good social life i've got to go
to first class honors i've got to do
youtube and so those three things alone
means you're quite busy and then you've
got family you know you want to see them
you want to be there for the big moments
so
i scheduled my time quite well such that
i think i got everything i wanted to get
done done but it just meant that i
couldn't waste time so i'd find myself
in lots of situations where
the the
the default option would be to just stay
and just chat with someone
but i had to be like right okay it's
nine i'm gonna go script bye do you
still have that kind of attitude today
so what i've found is like the larger
the channel has gotten the more i've
started to put my time at a premium oh
it's very much like that now except i
think i i am more in control of my time
and i'm more
i understand myself better so
for example i'll have situations well
i'll try and i'll try and set my life up
so that the minute i finish working i'm
with my friends
okay so for example i was scripting all
the way on the way here
and
i literally from here i'm off to meet a
friend
so so it's kind of like there's no dead
time
which in itself sounds stressful because
then you're planning every single minute
but it means you really look forward to
the times when you switch off because
you're completely switched off what does
that planning process look like for you
it's all in my head it's like a little
mental jigsaw okay
so
in the morning you decide here's what my
schedule looks like for the day or do
you plan out like a week in advance like
what does
it
look like i think i've just got
naturally quite good at just shuffling
things around in my brain such that i
kind of i have a guide in my head of
what needs to be done what point i can
switch off and that kind of thing okay
interesting but i always have these like
short-term things to look forward to as
well so for example this weekend i'm
really excited because i've got a party
tomorrow
and that party's been in my brain for
the last two or three weeks as a kind of
like way of making sure i get the things
i want to get done done and making them
more enjoyable to get done yeah yeah
like a lot of people talk about how
the majority of an enjoyment of an event
is in looking forward to the event and
then the event happens and then there is
some extra enjoyment and like reflecting
back on the event um so it sounds like
you're
kind of following i get a lot of
enjoyment just from looking forward to
things interesting i think because i
don't maybe do as many fun things as
other people i'd imagine most of my
enjoyment is the looking forward part of
it um what do you mean you don't do as
many fun things as other people because
i don't have that much time off i i
think
i think you must have found this as well
like as your channel starts to grow
because you're putting a higher premium
on your time it takes more to pull you
away from that and so the stuff that you
make time for has to be of higher
importance i guess
because the opportunity cost is higher
yeah do you find yourself thinking about
that in terms of
in terms of like social life and
relationships and friends and stuff as
well
i try not to but it's really hard to
separate yourself from it
you know when you're self-employed like
it your life does become one kind of
like jigsaw puzzle and
social life and work life do blend into
one sometimes you pull all-nighters
sometimes you have to just do it
so
i have had to cancel on people sometimes
and i hate cancelling on people i have
had to say no i can't come to your
wedding because i've got work to do
um
but more often than not i do make time
for the things that i think are
important
okay
and when you say that i can't come to
your wedding because i i have to i have
to do work like
i'm i i imagine people would find that a
bit strange because they're like you're
you're a big youtuber you control your
time you can do what you want you're
hashtag living the dream um
what what does it mean to kind of like
like you have to have to do work so i
think one thing that i do feel and i
need to get better at is almost like
a sense of fomo it's a sense that at any
point in time you're almost scared to
say yes i can come to your thing in two
months because you're not sure of what
opportunity is going to present itself
because so oftentimes i wake up i check
my inbox and probably once every two
days there is something that i think is
really really cool that i really want to
do
and i've had loads of situations where
i'm like i then check my calendar and
i'm like oh my god i can't do that
because i've said yes to this person for
this thing
and so if someone says can you book a
week off my wedding in italy in a year's
time i am naturally very very hesitant
to do that and i will delay as much as i
possibly can
and probably try to confirm two weeks
before what sort of emails are you
getting these like every two days like
do you want to forward them your way
yeah
i get none of these emails um i get
emails from like chinese charger
manufacturers being like hey can we can
we send you a review yeah i ignore them
oh i get those too yeah uh i got i got
some makeup ones as well actually hey
aaron we we love your beauty channel oh
i was like well thank you you know
it's all sorts of stuff but it's a lot
of it is like experience based like i
love the idea of like doing stuff that
feels different
um
i feel like i'm going off on a tangent
here but
i am of the philosophy that i want to do
something different every day right even
if that means on the way out to go to
work i kick the door so my like that
becomes the day my foot is hurting right
i want to lead a distinct life
and so when companies come to me and
offer experiences and they say okay
let's fly you around on a helicopter in
london to take footage with our new
phone it's hard kind of cool yeah it's
hard to say no
or like you know let's hire out a theme
park or let's do this video in a plane
and then you jump out that plane and
like all this stuff is constantly coming
in because i feel like this is like the
new age of influencers and every brand
wants to be a part of it
um obviously i have to turn down a lot
of those because i'm like a tech channel
and you have to like you know it's
integrity first so if a company wants
you to do some big you know brand
promotion you have to be very selective
but i want to filter out those
opportunities and make sure like i
consider all of them the fact that that
stuff comes in makes it harder for you
to say yes to things because then you
don't want to be like crap i said yes to
that thing like a year ago and now yeah
kind of yeah and then i'll be sitting at
like some baby shower thinking like i
could have been in like the dubai arena
right now you know crowd surfing or no
not crowd
who's the boss live show or something
like that oh
that's really cool um that you get this
the these sorts of well like when when
did that stuff start happening like what
stage of your channel do you start
getting offers to fly in helicopters and
things like that pretty recently pretty
recently i'm not adjusted to it by any
means um it's like probably in the last
year um i think what happens is like
there is an element with youtube of
exponential growth right providing that
you use the data you're given you
um respond to the comments that have
been sort of left in terms of like you
take their feedback on board and keep
improving you will see a trajectory and
so like i think in the last year my
channel's gone from like three million
to nearly nine million um and if you go
back it's a similar kind of like jump
each year proportionally
so
the difference in like value you're
giving to a brand and nine million
versus three million is enormous
and it's also that kind of status shift
of like okay this is a big influencer to
this is the biggest tech influencer in
like europe right so it's like you're
the go-to person yeah
so that makes a difference too and then
all of a sudden your inbox gets flooded
with all these all these cool things and
yeah um
one thing that i
find on a lower scale is like
we we we talked about kind of like
valuing your time
and
you know there's a few a few people talk
about you this idea of setting and
setting your own personal hourly rate
and then not doing things that are not
making more than that hourly rate or if
you can if you don't like doing
something you can outsource it for less
than the hourly rate then then that's
all good
um and so i kind of followed this
semi-religiously to eliminate things
like laundry from my life i'm like well
you know that even that 15 minutes i
spent hanging up clothing if i just
outsourced it and i spent that 15
minutes scripting a video well that's
significantly more valuable to my
business and my life than that 15
minutes of doing laundry
but then it's very easy to start
thinking hmm is it really worth you know
x thousand dollars to hang out with that
friend for two hours and i like
you know
at one point probably about a year ago i
started to find myself thinking in those
terms i was like okay no no like there's
got to be like some sort of separation
between the socials like real life and
the business
how did you do that recognizing that
when it comes to so like so
recognizing that ultimately
relationships is the most important
thing in life and
i you know when you read these books
around you know top five regrets of the
dying and so on
um it's always around i wish i hadn't
worked so hard i wish i'd made more time
for my friends
um
there was uh you know the other day
there was a scenario in which
i could have had a sleepover at a
friend's place and we would have kind of
chilled until the early hours of the
morning and then woken up at like 11 11
a.m
or i could have gone home early woken up
at a reasonable hour and
done three extra hours of writing on my
book and i thought hmm
you know a few weeks from now will i
remember more the hangout with this
friend or the three hours of writing for
my book clearly the three i was writing
for my book are going to be more roi
positive but there is some
intangible social value for my life and
for my memories and stuff around hanging
out with friends instead i think that
that intangibility makes it really hard
when you're trying to view the world in
black and white isn't it it's like okay
you can measurably see the value of
doing your work but you can't measurably
see the value of hanging out with your
friends even though it's there it's
programmed into us we need that
interaction i think because we can't
measure it that's probably where the
disconnect happens yeah i think so and i
think like when
when you were describing how you
managed your time at uni that was that
was that was fairly similar to how i
would do mine as well in that
i i i had this kind of diminishing
returns curve of social interaction in
my mind oh god so i was like you know i
could spend
an hour at this party or i could spend
three hours at this party and if i just
go for an hour i will get 95 of the
value and if i stay for the extra three
hours there's really nothing more to be
gained and there was a very like um
liberating moment when i realized that
if i'm at a party i can just leave
whenever i want even without saying
goodbye and no one will really notice
because everyone else is like you know
tipsy or drunk at this point so i can
just leave and like edit a video and
then all of a sudden i was like i can
have my cake and eat it too as long as i
keep diminishing returns in mind
so i'm laughing because i think i
thought the exact same thing um but also
at that point are you enjoying being at
the party well what's the point going at
all is it to try and maintain
connections with
people who
you don't like that much
yeah i i had a weird weird attitude
towards parties in that i thought i
should enjoy them and i thought i should
be that become the sort of person who
enjoys parties because i wanted to be
like confident charismatic and all that
jazz
and uh to break away from my massive
nerd unconfident guy that i was in
school
um
and then
it was it was actually a few years into
uni where i was having like a dmc with
some some friends around parties and
even my cool friends said that they
didn't enjoy parties i was like whoa
that was that was my blog i was like
wait a minute if the cool kids don't
enjoy parties and actually everyone
seems to prefer like intimate dinners of
like you know four or five people max
that's like vibes then
why am i forcing myself to attend these
parties just for the sake of it yeah so
then once i realized that kind of my
attendance and parties significantly
dipped
okay so
traversing the timeline back to you're
at university you start to take the
youtube channel seriously
um you start to kind of
split your time between aiming for a
first class having some semblance of the
social life and also continuing to do
the youtube thing
um
were there well
you know i'm big on like productivity
hacks and time management hacks and
stuff other other than the kind of
curtailing social interaction to be on
the point of diminishing returns did you
use any other kind of strategies in
hindsight that that helped you make the
time for all this kind of stuff i think
the big thing for me was seeing things
as
bonuses
um it's the idea of not punishing
yourself for not doing things but
encouraging yourself to do things
so in my head when i was sort of setting
up the day
i would try to tell myself okay your
goal is not necessarily to finish this
youtube video but it's to kind of like
film a part of it and then what i tend
to find is that when i pick up my camera
i'm like okay i might as well do the
whole thing and i would feel even better
at the end of the day because i've done
more than i asked of myself um but also
sometimes when i just couldn't do it all
i wouldn't feel bad and then sleep
terribly and have nightmares about tech
videos i would just be like well you
know it's fine i did what i needed to do
okay so like setting low expectations
for yourself and then being happier when
you
when you sort of surpass those
expectations yeah and and it's tricky to
do when you're ambitious because on one
hand i was trying to become like you
know uk's biggest tech youtuber and it's
tough to do that when you have to temper
your own expectations but it was almost
like a really deliberate thing i did
for my own mental health one thing that
came up when i was when we were kind of
researching your vibes is that you seem
to be quite big on goal setting
um in that you tweeted at the start of
the year that all right
new goals for the year 10 million
subscribers on on youtube a million
followers on twitter and i think a
million for us on instagram uh and
you've now hit that milestone on twitter
and instagram and basically
basically i'm gonna hit it on youtube as
well which is awesome
um
i don't think i'm going to make it this
year but it's close enough close enough
um
it strikes me that this is in stark
contrast to at the start when you're 50
and you're like i'm just going to make
videos for fun
at what point did your goals shift to
i'm aiming to be the uk's largest tech
youtuber
so i've always actually been very
numbers driven so even at the start when
i didn't really have a schedule i still
had like sheets on my wall of like how
many subscribers i wanted to hit okay
i've always had that in me and actually
to be honest i think as the channel's
grown i've sort of tried to detach
myself as much as possible from those
numbers
because youtube is one of those things
that you just
you can't win
so i mean
there's an element
there is a point when you start to think
like what am i chasing here like how is
my life different when i'm at 10 million
versus 9 million or 9 million versus 1
million you know at a certain point
you're making a living it's your
business you're comfortable
and so
you have to kind of separate yourself
from that you can't tie yourself
to a number that you have no control
over
i i i agree wholeheartedly um
but you were doing that at start yeah
okay
why because so at the start it was like
i was very much thinking of it in terms
of like that conversation i had with my
friend where we're like oh my god 10 000
people that's so many people let's try
and get to that goal okay um but it's
it's very much after passing like a
million subscribers for example which in
my head was this inconceivable number
that it was like oh if you pass a
million you're just like you're a
celebrity you know um and it's when you
pass that and then you have this point
of internal reflection where it's like i
have just achieved everything i ever set
out to and more
why why am i not elated all the time
that you're like okay well actually this
isn't as important as i thought it was
so the numbers for you it sounds like
the numbers for you were motivating in
the early stages with like the numbers
on the wall and the subscriber counts
and things like that yeah the reason i
do it now like the reason i've got this
pinned tweet saying we want to hit this
this and this is it's partly as a kind
of
a bit of a challenge like a fun thing to
do um but a lot of it is just to get
other people on board like my followers
on board with kind of where my head's at
what i'm aiming for it gives them
something to kind of like aim for as
well with me but at the same time so
you're you're setting this goal for
yourself as a bit of a challenge but at
the same time you are also detached like
you're trying to detach your personal
sense of self-worth from the hitting of
the goal yes yeah i i'm not i'm not
going to be upset if we don't hit 10
million this year i've been thinking a
lot about goal setting um
because i am writing a book themed
around productivity where the core
message is that
really the secret to productivity is to
enjoy enjoy yourself because if you're
enjoying the journey and having fun then
productivity takes care of itself as
like
the general theme
and the first chapter which i've been
working on a draft of like
in the last two weeks is about setting
goals
and
my personal philosophy on goal setting
has always been that i've not really
been a fan of goals like that you said
that are outside of my control and so
when i started the youtube channel the
goal was one or two videos a week for
the next five years and that's
that's all i'm gonna
that that's the goal because i actually
have that fully within my control
of being able to do that myself it's
like an input goal
whereas
if i were to think like like for example
in in in writing this book at some point
my goal was
i want to publish a book that hits the
new york times best seller list
and whenever i would think of that as
being a goal it would be very
demotivating and i would end up
procrastinating and not doing anything
because it would feel like ev every what
i write now has to be a best-selling
word and
the the i really ramped up the stakes
and i wasn't enjoying the process
anymore and then i shifted the goal to
to be honest i just want to write a book
i'm proud of and i like writing i like
reading and i'm probably going to keep
writing books for the rest of my life so
hey this is just a book norman who gets
it's i just want to write something i'm
proud of all of a sudden i was like damn
this is just immediately makes it so
much more fun to to try and go towards
this goal and i've still got the new
york times list in the back of my mind
because you know it's like any actor
wants the oscars any anymore
it's a stretch goal yeah um
but i try not to think about it because
for me personally it like leads to sort
of
sadness and demotivation
what what's your what's your take on
that pretty similar to yours um i think
to start with i was very much of the
opinion that if i tell myself to make
one or two videos a week then the lazy
part of my brain is going to try and
make two bad videos a week because it
can still achieve that goal
while putting in less effort
but then as the channel grew it was like
i almost trusted myself a bit more it's
like if i tell myself i'm going to do
two videos a week then i know that i'll
make sure they're good videos so the
goal was kind of a quality metric
quality bar for you as well
at what point did you decide i want to
be the uk's biggest tech youtuber
presumably it wasn't at the age of 15.
no no
it was towards the tail end of uni it
actually worked out quite well because
you know i was busy at uni um and to be
honest it was some part of it was
frustrating because it was like i had
this vision but i also had finals and uh
finals are not easy
so it's kind of like very much like a
flurry of like like a whirlwind of just
running around completing various tasks
and then the second uni ended i felt so
so like on it i just had every hour of
my waking day to just spend on youtube
it was so liberating
and i use them all on youtube
what was your um sort of pwc
saga
yeah so
so i say to people when they're younger
try as many things as possible because
if you don't you will end up down some
sort of path
right it's just not necessarily the path
that you want to go down
and i think that's where i was because i
was kind of you know i was good at maths
i was good at writing essays and so i
was just kind of you know i picked the
subjects that i was strong at and that
funnels you into economics and then that
funnels you into a certain job and so i
was kind of sitting there in my price
waterhouse internship which is quite you
know it's fairly prestigious
but i was not having a good time like i
didn't get on that well with the people
i just thought the work was
mind-numbingly boring and i was like i
was sat at my office sketching youtube
ideas
yeah price waterhouse um don't tell them
but but it was definitely a realization
of like oh my god i've got to change
something this can't be my life i got
offered the job appeared up pearly city
and then at that point after really
thinking about it and evaluating it i
turned it down
which makes the whole saga seem entirely
pointless like why did you go to school
to go to uni to go to you know to get
this job to then
quit
before you started
um but i think all those things needed
to happen for me to realize
that youtube was an option and it was a
better option
oh
this is interesting this so so this
mirror is my my my exact kind of train
of thought over the last few months yeah
because
a year ago i
took a break from medicine as as one
does after two years working as a doctor
it's very standard to take a gap i'm
sure you've got friends who are medics
um and i was intending to like travel
the world and stuff and then the
pandemic happened and it just happened
that during the pandemic the youtube
channel really started to take off uh
for
you know probably pandemic related
reasons people are at home quite a lot
everyone wants to be more productive
have a side hustle all of those things
that i was talking about started to do
really well
and it's only in the last few months
that i've really been thinking because i
always had in the back of my mind that
youtube is my side hustle and i do
medicine as my main gig and
in the last probably a few weeks i
kind of admitted to myself that i'm
probably never going to be a doctor
again
and that was that was like really scary
because
you know there was there was the element
of sunk cost uh but you know having read
a lot of daniel kahneman stuff i was
like okay some course fallacy like who
cares yeah it doesn't matter that i've
spent six years at uni and two years
working
um to get to this point there was also
an element of
fear
in that um well there were two aspects
of fear one was
what if
i what if what if i get cancelled and
everything disappears then at least i'll
be able to be a doctor again as like a a
fullback backup option but the other
element of fear which i think was
stronger was
that i built my brand off the back of
hey i'm a doctor went to cambridge
bloody blah blah blah here is a video
about productivity if i now stop being a
doctor will people think that
am i just a youtuber yeah and did
does my kind of internet career now
now is is is that going to suffer as a
result of losing this badge of
this badge of prestige
it's like what are you then yeah exactly
what the hell am i like yeah how do i
how do i describe myself for someone
else what do you do it's like oh i make
videos on the internet yeah um did you
have any of those thoughts as you were
leaving a fairly
traditional prestigious career that
you'd worked for years to get to
the back up thing was definitely in my
mind like having a backup option
um
i think youtube definitely felt like a
risk more so at that point when it was
like you can jump you can make this leap
onto this new thing than it does looking
back now i think when you look back it's
always easier to be like oh yeah of
course i made the right decision and it
was obvious and yeah but it wasn't at
the time yeah i remember having that
thought process when i was in my final
year of
of uni where the youtube channel i think
had not even hit a thousand subscribers
at that point i was i was on like video
number 35 i was on like 400 subscribers
and i was thinking okay i've got finals
coming up i could take finals seriously
or i could take youtube seriously
and i was like okay i'm pretty confident
that based on my current medical
knowledge i could pass finals just not
do very well
and i'm pretty confident that i'm out of
the running for a distinction because of
the way the numbers worked out so i was
like okay every percentage point i get
above a pass mark is therefore kind of
wasted effort
assuming there's no correlation between
performance as a doctor and performance
on written exams which most people said
it wasn't
um so i threw everything into youtube at
the time
so you're in a position where with very
low effort you could get a pass with
extremely high effort
to potentially maybe probably not even
be in the running for a distinction
right
uh so i thought let's go youtube all the
way and ended up kind of just scraping a
pass in written finals and then thinking
okay cool so that worked out let's take
it seriously for the clinical stuff
which actually matters
um but and in hindsight that was like uh
obviously the right thing to do but at
the time it felt very much like a hmm
i'm not sure this youtube thing has legs
but i know i'm gonna kick myself if i
don't give it a go yeah you never assume
that your channel is going to be like
the one to hit a million yeah yeah yeah
like i i i think i think at the time i
was thinking oh my god if i can hit 4
000 subscribers then like that's like
the best thing ever then i had that i
was like
10k 10k you're just naming numbers
gives you like access to the youtube
space oh my god
um and it just like the numbers just
stop stop meaning anything after a while
when you stop being able to visualize
them because like 10 000 it's like well
my school hall could fit a thousand
people like
10 schools that's a lot of people and
then but beyond that it's just really
hard to take
it is as soon as you get to six digits
it's i don't think we have any grasp of
it we can't yeah so you did the
internship you decided to turn down the
job offer and now you're going full time
on the youtube thing can you remember
what
what were your stats at the time like
what was your sub count
what was that right i think yeah
250k subscribers okay um the revenue
wasn't amazing i think it was just a bit
more than the pwc job like the entrant
kind of job because ad revenue wasn't as
much then
um
there was no sponsorships at all because
i think it's partly because i didn't
know how to get them yeah and also the
infrastructure wasn't there like you
know five six seven years ago where
brands were kind of hopping on and
agencies were approaching you okay
so you're on 250k subs uh kind of making
a living but not like a baller living
what did your
what did your life look like then like
24 7 youtube what was that was the vibe
so as soon as i left uni like i said i
had this kind of like i was relieved
from the pressure of having to juggle
many things so i felt free
but also at the same time i pushed
myself really hard i think there was
this thing in my head of like youtube is
one of those platforms who knows how
long it's going to be there for while
you've got this opportunity run with it
so i made a video like every single day
it was just me in my back garden just
getting tech investing in stuff to then
cover to then try and sell and make a
bit of a loss on and yeah all that kind
of stuff yeah a video every single day
how long do you keep that up for
about six months ish
yeah what did you what did your like day
in the life look like then like at the
time it was it sounds like because in
one day you've got to do everything
you've got to script your video in the
morning you've got to film your video in
the afternoon you then go to edit your
video in the evening so it's very much a
case of like
complete day packed you don't have much
time for other things if you take a day
off to go see a friend then it's two
videos the next day
um
yeah it was nuts and it did take me to
sort of a breaking point i guess where i
i was like okay this isn't sustainable
i'm going to try a different strategy
how did you realize that this wasn't
sustainable
um so there was one point it was like a
really really hot day and i was kind of
like i was filming with my camera but i
was like kind of like straining my skin
hurt i was like super tired and some
reason i just started crying i'm not a
crier but i just started crying because
i was in so much like pain
from the kind of like long-term
exhaustion and the exhaustion in the
moment
and
it was at that point that i was like i
can't i can't finish this video i i just
physically i just couldn't do it
and then i was like okay it's fine i'm
not gonna post a video tomorrow i'll
i'll figure it out
um even though i was horrified at the
thought of like not seeing that uptick
in subscribers and be like wasted
opportunity
but then when i found out that it was
okay you know my channel was still alive
then i was like okay maybe i'll do one
every two days or one every three days
and i think when you give yourself that
space to be able to take your time with
things you can do them better and that
was actually a really important moment
to be able to kind of like
make better videos if i hadn't given
myself that space i might still be doing
one video a day and they'd be terrible
yeah so you start off with the quantity
thing because you're thinking that you
know this is what the algorithm needs i
need i need to feed the machine yeah and
then you have a moment where you're like
okay
maybe quantity is now no longer serving
me let's switch to quality yeah i've had
to say
i think also you can actually you can
enjoy the process a bit more when you
take time with things
like doing things like just to a strict
schedule all the time is really just
tiring and it means you don't get any
time to be creative
or you know do anything fun
yeah i i had this moment a couple of a
couple of weeks ago where
you know there was the there was
there was a video we put out on the
channel maybe last month
which
you know ended up getting like a ton of
dislikes for a very clickbaity kind of
title i was like all the comments were
like oh my god i can't believe what your
channel is turned into like this is
awful sorted out i was like okay this is
actually all these are all very
reasonable comments um people have a
point here so i deleted the video and
that kind of led me on the
soul-searching mission of like okay how
did we get to this point where i put out
something that was objectively [ __ ] um
for the sake of i don't know what and i
did like i had i had a few hours on a
saturday i think it was about two or
three weeks ago in in here where i was
just sitting in the
in the communal spot by myself for like
five hours and i was intending to film a
video but i thought you know what i'm
just going to open up apple notes and
just do some journaling and figure out
why i'm feeling a bit weird about this
youtube stuff
and i realized that i'd been drinking
the consistency kool-aid for so long
that i just assumed we have to put out
two videos a week and yeah we've got a
sponsor every week so we just have to
put out a video every tuesday and every
every sunday it's just one of the laws
of physics it has to be done yeah and
then i started
i realized that a big part of why i've
been feeling a bit disconnected from the
channel recently is because
this drive for
of a video like
two videos a week on the topic of like
kind of productivity personal
development stuff where i've kind of
said the stuff that needs to be said and
now it's like we're really scraping the
bottom of the barrel trying to come up
with ideas
meant that we were putting out videos
that i wasn't happy with and then i
thought okay what if i just
don't stick to that schedule anymore and
i did kind of tim ferriss's fear setting
exercise and you know what's the worst
that can happen one of the worst case
scenarios and wrote them all out in in
detail
and realized that actually these are all
these worst case scenarios are pretty
unlikely and
you know having done this for now for
four and a half years focusing on
quantity we can now shift to focusing on
quality and not being wedded to an
upload schedule or not being wedded to
this video has to come out at this
certain time to appease this particular
sponsor because if we want to drop the
sponsor in it like it doesn't matter who
cares um and then
that felt like ridiculously liberating
and as i was doing one of these i think
as i was doing one of these tim ferriss
exercises of like what's the worst case
scenario i was like tearing up a bit
thinking like oh my god like all of this
has gotten to this point where i can be
like you know what
like
i can take a step back and it's not
going to be the end of the world yeah um
a realization that you have control yeah
yeah um and it was very
like the that thing you said where
you're almost you know i can't go to a
friend's wedding because i have work
i've found myself thinking of those
terms these last few months especially
as our team has expanded now and we've
got like
16 20 people ish depending on how you
come four times and part time
um but i found most of my time being
spent on being a manager and sort of
zoom call after zoom call meeting after
meeting after meeting and no time for
actually
thinking about videos and filming
content and stuff which is the thing
that i love doing
and one of my friends who was i was like
i was i was living with is a doctor
working in a e
where his schedule was like ridiculously
absurd and he was like right i've got a
day off do you want to grab dinner and i
was like oh god
no look at my calendar sorry i'm like
i've got 20 minutes of time between like
10 p.m and 10 20 p.m and then i have a
call with someone from the us at 10 20
and he was like dude what are you doing
it's yeah that's bad when you realize
your schedule's worth and worse than
theirs yeah um so now we're like okay
take a step back i'm going to focus on
the content angus is going to kind of
manage the business side of things and
trying to find more of a more of a
middle ground there
um but it sounds like that's similar to
the experience you had on the whole like
quality quantity thing
yes back then yeah yeah i think i still
need to do work on it internally um but
more and more i do want to focus on the
things i'm good at and the things i'm
needed for so i never want to veer away
from not
being the presence on my channel i don't
want other hosts and things like that
so if it means having less staff and
having a
smaller operation overall that's that's
fine by me because i i love doing the
core parts of it so we're at this point
you've done a video every day for a
whole six months
and then you decide okay we can take the
foot off the pedal on quantity and focus
on quality
what what happens next on the channel
there wasn't some sudden miraculous kind
of like oh this this worked this was the
secret um but i think you know i did an
economics degree i'm very data driven as
it is so i guess it's this kind of like
slow
but measured level of improvement from
video to video as you're kind of like
looking at retention graphs and being
like oh you know loads of people dropped
off there i'm not going to do that again
and kind of like from video to video
when you're still doing content
regularly there's so much information
available about what works and what
doesn't
you know i don't i don't think any other
company or creator
gets what you do as a substantially
sized youtuber in terms of like metrics
to evaluate yourself with yeah um
companies would pay ridiculous amounts
of money for data that like that yeah
so if you know how to use it it's
extremely powerful how how how do you
use it i don't look at my metrics at all
so i would love to learn from you about
like what can i be doing how much time
do you spend in the youtube analytics i
look at it for every single video that i
post so two days after it's gone live
i'll kind of i'll spend a good half an
hour just going through it being like
what countries did this hit how long did
those people stay on for when did the
majority drop off was there a
significant spike or a significant dip
did certain parts make people go back
things like that
because you can see all of it it's like
why wouldn't you
well you don't but i think you should
yeah i really think i should as well
like yeah so i found things like for
example if i asked people to subscribe
really early in the video it was
detrimental because you'd get
a drop of like 20 percent of viewers
potentially
but
they wouldn't be subscribing they'd just
be irritated by the fact you've asked
them to subscribe without showing them
why
um because at the start of a video in
the first like 15 seconds people are
very very easy to lose
it's at that point that they decide
whether they're going to you know full
screen you and kind of invest in this
video or whether they're gonna you know
click on one of the 30 that are kind of
grabbing their attention from the side
how should i start
if i if i if you're like if you were
like kind of my youtube mentor or
whatever like how would you advise me to
start looking at retention graphs and
analytics a bit more what's what's like
a good a good starting point
um i would look for troughs so look at
kind of points where you've got viewers
that are stable and then when they go
down
and try to identify why they've gone
down at that point so for example one of
the other things i found was like
i would do a round off at the end of a
video and at the point where you start
rounding off a video anyone who feels
like they've got it yeah they're like
okay i'm done this is the end of the
video and so instead what i've started
doing is the the second i finish the key
content
i'm talking about the next video
so it's literally like and that's what
happened to samsung okay for the video
on this that's there for the video on
this that's there and i found
immediately that like the amount of
clicks i was getting on my end cards to
lead to the next video where like they
tripled
and so my outro now has my face in it it
didn't used to have my face in it it
just used to be this kind of blaring
music but now it feels like a
continuation of the main content yeah
and i'm kind of being like look over
there look over there and they can see
me pointing to videos
um
and i think actually i think you said
this once uh not that long ago actually
that the people who watch till the end
are the most valuable audience members
because they're more likely to follow
through right yeah yeah so the the the
end card thing is something that we
started doing as well uh about about a
year ago and it and it worked really
nicely but kind of beyond that i didn't
really
i don't really look at the numbers
because it's scary it's yeah it's scary
it also feels like and i don't know if
this is a relic of my kind of olden days
of like
just i think i have to drunk the
consistency kool-aid way too much where
it's like once you made a video then
forget about the video on to the next
one
and
the kind of one percent improvements
over time
i think i've been doing from my own gut
of like oh it would be cool if the next
video had this thing
and especially when i was editing my own
videos that was a lot easier to do now
that there's like a layer between me and
the video being edited it's actually
harder especially because our editor
question is in romania it's it's it's a
lot harder to affect change
even with the whole remote thingy and
even with like frame i o and all this
all this other stuff that i'm now even
thinking to the point of like let's get
christian to switch to final cut pro so
he can send me the project file and i
can i can do the final cut myself
um so that i can then have more finely
tuned control over what's going on in
the video i can understand that like
i've not still fully handed off stuff
that i probably should have handed off
because it's your baby right it's your
face it's your voice it's your it's your
name
um so i understand that um but to be
honest i've actually benefited a lot
from having two people it's not a big
team but two people who are specialists
in their area and who like i can hand
things to and i know they'll do them
better than i would okay
well what does your team look like right
now so it's editor camera guy
okay it's very very basic but it's my
camera garm editor they're very very
good at their jobs to the point where
i'm like if i've got any piece of
graphics i want doing i will consult
them because i know that they'll know
better than me
oh how long have you had those guys for
uh editor for about three years camera
guy for about a year
do you do any of the editing yourself
now i do it as a last resort if there's
like something really urgent which there
does tend to be with tech like you know
if apple does an event you want to react
to it
you're editing that video um because you
can't ask your employees to stay up all
night although they do that actually
voluntarily but i don't ask them um
but yeah so i'll do it if i have to
and like well one thing that really
strikes me about your videos is that
basically every second there is
something going on and i can't help but
continuing to watch it and then the meta
part of me is thinking
ah i love like all of these different
things that are going on to make me
encourage and encourage me to keep
watching this and the content itself is
very valuable
and so i think one thing that we do well
on this on on my channel is that the
content is broadly valuable but we do
basically nothing when it comes to the
visual side of things and it may as well
be a podcast yes and i think like that
anytime i see one of your videos i feel
like ridiculously inspired like oh my
god like the amount of post production
that's gone into this it's insane it's a
kind of the the way i describe it is a
an aggregation of micro refinements
so it's like all that stuff hasn't
happened overnight if you kind of go
back through the channel and watch one
video every year you'd see a few new
things each time so like the day that i
decided okay i'm gonna spend more time
on music and try to create moods with
what i'm saying the day i decided to put
my face in a circle so i'm visible at
all times
and we've tried these experiments looked
at those graphs seen that they've worked
and then realized okay these are
mainstays data is is it like
you have a gut feeling that when i put
my face on the thing while showing
overlay it will work and then you
actually and then you look at the data
or yeah yeah exactly that so you have a
gut feeling you try it it works or it
doesn't work and then you action it and
how can you how can you tell like you
adding your face versus not adding a
face it's not like you're releasing the
same video face no face so you have a
control
it's tough but like
i think when you spend that much time
with the data you have a gauge on how
well a certain video will keep people
okay so for example i know that if i
make a camera comparison they don't have
good retention like an average camera
comparison might have 45 50 retention
okay right and so if you do a camera
comparison and it gets 55 percent you're
like that is an outlier oh okay or if i
do an unboxing or a top ten if i do a
top ten that's going to get really good
retention and so you'll know what to
expect and in your top tens you start
out or you start from number 10 rather
than number one always and
you go so something like you know and it
starts off it starts off a and then
becomes b and then becomes positively c
and it's like it's all so
it's just so clever
i spend a lot of time on the scripts um
and the other thing i do actually is
when i'm scripting i'm thinking of three
different people okay so there's three
people i know in my life of different
levels of i guess tech enthusiasm and so
with every line i've almost reached the
stage where i'm scanning it being like
is this interesting to all these three
people would they watch this would they
watch this would they watch this would
they understand this is this funny to
them all that kind of stuff
and i think when you do that you end up
with a script that is a little more
broadly appealing than it would
otherwise be
how much time do you spend on scripting
that's that's most of what i do
okay so like for a standalone let's say
for a kind of google pixel versus iphone
13 pro camera comparison 22 minute long
video so that would is it 20 minutes 22
minutes yeah
oh yeah that was your toilet break that
was my toilet break yeah
i'm watching that double speed obviously
um i think that was probably three and a
half days of scripting three and a half
days yeah
of like are we talking eight hour days
no we're talking like 14 hour days we're
talking like
for 42 hours spent on scripting a single
video ages and eight minutes ages
because i do the initial kind of like
what i think is going to happen yeah
then i test the phones and kind of like
because remember like what i'm saying
i am having to create my own findings
i'm not taking things and like doing you
know
passing them on yeah so you have to make
sure for every single thing you say it
is correct
and that that is one thing that i almost
wouldn't i wouldn't trust anyone else
with because it's my name and my yeah
as well yeah yeah yeah so i know how to
test these products but it takes time
bloody hell
what about for like a stand like you see
so you did a video that was um
ways in which tech is bad uh or so
i'm worried about humans yes yeah that
was a bit of a departure from your
phones it was vibe yeah um
you're not gonna like this
it took about eight days of scripting i
think
so about 100 hours of scripting
something like that yeah i wasn't i
wasn't keeping track but it was a long
time
it's the kind of time that like the
practical part of me is thinking like
is this time well spent
um but sometimes i kind of like i get
carried away thinking about how viewers
are gonna think you know i'm thinking
about these three different categories
of viewers and
um
and then sometimes scripts get away away
from you it's like okay this should be a
12 minute video and then you actually
try and do it and you're like oh my god
that's 25 26 minutes
so sometimes things add up out of your
control
and i don't tamper them because
sometimes i'm like
it's okay this is going to be a big
project this is going to do really well
over time it's going to hit the youtube
criteria it's fine we'll spend more time
on it i was once watching an interview
with penn and teller you know the
magicians yeah um
where
they were
it was it was at some kind of magic
convention of some of some sort
um because i was super cool into
close-up magic back in the day i left
close up match
i should exchange some tricks sometimes
uh i actually have a few decks of cards
in here that someone gifted anyway um
some someone asked like they did some
like ridiculous special on like uh david
letterman or something
and pen was describing how the how they
did it and they were like i mean we we
literally
hired a cockroach firm
to
put 10 000 cockroaches in this tank
shipped it across i don't know the
atlantic to the david letterman show
like three months before our appearance
built some stuff into the thing and it's
just like in a really elaborate process
and he said and there and they said
something like
um often
magic is spending more time than anyone
thinks is reasonable on doing a thing
and that was kind of what i was thinking
when you're like bringing
50 hours of scripting for a 20 minute
camera comparison 100 hours of scripting
for a a listicle about ways in which
you're worried about tech like yeah
that's just insane
i don't maybe i don't there's a lot of
classes because like like you're doing
your factual pass yeah or you go through
and you're like okay i said that the
pixel's camera was better than the
iphones in this so when you're checking
that you've then got to go take these
phones out and just like take loads and
loads of photos to make sure it's right
yeah and then you're doing like a a fun
pass are there enough fun bits and are
they scattered in the right places like
we plan a lot of the jokes we're gonna
make and like the things that are gonna
be thrown at me during the video and
stuff like that like
because we want to make sure that there
are points of respite because obviously
it's a tech video right it's going to be
very heavy on information and no one
wants to sit through 25 minutes of pure
like this isn't
uni yeah so you have to kind of think
about those things and you end up doing
all these passes
and that adds so much time to it and
you're still making like sometimes three
videos a week sometimes more than that
like it's not three it's probably a
video a week right now the goal is two
videos a week two really good videos a
week but i think i need more people to
be able to do that bloody hell okay and
then when you're testing the cameras for
example you've got your camera guy who's
like
filming you testing the cameras and and
stuff yeah our processes are efficient
given that we only have two people but
they could be more efficient if we had
five yeah um
i think i want to be in a position where
i'm only doing the things that i want to
do and the things that i need to do okay
and so right now there are still a few
situations where i'm not doing that
but i'm getting there
what what i don't what i wouldn't want
is like a huge corporate structure and
twenty people yeah like people would
like middle management so that would be
horrible
we've got a few of them in this video
absolutely
tell me more about your about your
process for videos like i'm gonna i'm
going full selfish murder i just wanna i
just wanna learn from you here so
before
i think most youtubers
when you reach a certain size you start
planning videos backwards so when you
think about a video you're thinking
about thumbnail title would people click
on it
um and then from there you're like okay
what's the content going to be like is
it engaging is it delivering value will
people finish that video thinking whoa i
like this guy and then at that point
then you're thinking you take a step
further back it's like okay what's the
storyline what's the subplot how are you
keeping people throughout that video
engaged and then you work all the way
back and then that's the point where
you've got your content you know what
your next step is but the way the normal
the trigger point is either an idea i've
had embedded
or some past video that did really well
that people really enjoyed and they're
like can we have a part two yeah or
something someone else has done that i
think that's a really interesting idea
what if i applied it to phones or you
know gadgets or whatever i really got a
sense that there was a story line
because you were like i'm going to tell
you about this product but there's like
but but there's a question here like
who's it for and it was like you were
you kept on that was like a thread going
through going through the content
and all that stuff is the stuff that you
do
in your kind of multiple passes of
figuring out
it's almost like writing a book it is
in my head like i never thought i'd
write as much as i do
like when i was a kid i thought i'll be
doing something where i'm working on an
excel spreadsheet or something it didn't
occur to me that my job is basically
video essays
video essays
it's an interesting way but that is what
it is i think i've almost like
i've moved into my own like this tech
youtube and i do that yeah but i think
i'm moving more towards like the
analytical side of things yeah where i'm
trying to break down things from an
economics perspective
yeah like you did a kind of journey
versus someone some samsung video which
was
very interesting you did like uh things
you didn't know about tesla video which
was very interesting and this like kind
of why why why i hate humanity or that
why tech is destroying the world
type and i as seeing those i was just
like really surprised i was like oh i
wonder what this video is going to be
like that's like bloody hell this is a
really good video
were you concerned moving away from the
niche inverted commas of phones into
this more like analytical type stuff
yeah i actually so
at the start of my channel the tech was
very broad and actually so the focus was
gaming consoles because that's what i
was interested in at the time
and then there was a point when i
decided to focus on phones because i
didn't want to have a fragmented
audience but what i was found finding
even early on is that because i was
making videos on so many different
things i had 20 percent of my audience
who wanted to see gaming consoles 20
want to see headphones wants to pc
phones and that meant that every single
time i posted a video only 20 of people
would like want to see that
and so i decided actually okay phones
i'm interested in phones there is you
know reliable big recurring market i'm
gonna focus on that but then when you
get to a certain size being niche caps
you yeah so i'm now starting to think
about things like i would like to cover
laptops i am interested in those two
i'll bring those in or cars or other
things like that do you use a
teleprompter i've started using a
teleprompter
two months ago okay what's that what's
that been like
it helps
so i'm obsessive with my videos right i
script them to the word yeah and so if
you're going to have that kind of
production a teleprompter makes so much
sense it reduces the kind of the stress
on the day of filming and it means you
can get through it faster and we've had
scripts where
for like
for some videos i've sat there for four
and a half hours straight like just
filming
before the teleprompter and that video
you could do in like half the time with
a teleprompter
wait a minute you're filming for four
and a half hours on a video that's fully
scripted yeah yeah why does it take so
long because i
i start thinking about like how i should
be pronouncing certain things and what
emphasis i need to put on what words and
all of a sudden you start retaking your
sentences again and again and again and
again
and apologizing to your cameraman for
having to kind of like redo the movement
and then also it's like for these fun
bits so for example i've got a video
coming up where we're trying to make a
phone levitate to just because i'm
saying that the phone feels alive and so
at that point we're like okay let's tie
it to fishing wire and let's lift it
while i'm doing that but that takes so
much time to get right because you've
got to get your inflection right and at
the same time you've got to make sure
that that's lifted it doesn't fall on
you the screen is facing the right way
and it adds so much variables and then
we're trying to bring in like the cats
every now and again for like in like
little breaks and you can't control the
cats very easily so
normally one once per video i'm like
going downstairs shouting milo like
several times until he comes and like i
take him up feed him
it just adds up it just bloody hell okay
so
you put uh an unreasonable amount of
time in scripting and also it seems an
unreasonable amount of time in filming
to get all the things right yeah yeah
and it's like how
i i don't think anyone anyone watching
your videos would would think that your
20 minute video took four hours to film
yeah yeah sometimes people like they
leave comments like
uh so sometimes i make a battery test
video where i've got like eight phones
on the table and like you can see their
batteries run down and people leave a
comment like this man spent eight hours
giving us this um you know amazing video
or something useful video
and what they don't realize is that
eight hours was just the start of it
uh to take to set up that table for that
video was a four-hour job in itself
because you have to do things like have
you ever seen these videos so the camera
is like locked above yeah the battery
ones yeah yeah where it's like a
time-lapse of like traffic right now so
every single phone is taped to the table
multiple times so that it doesn't budge
the camera every hinge of the camera is
taped together so that the camera
doesn't budge um
there's so many things that happen like
we're using like laser pointers to make
sure it's perfectly vertical yeah um
like you have to do image corrections to
make sure there's no distortion
like
there's more there's more to it
if you want it because i'm quite
perfectionist like i want it to be a
certain way and when you're like that
you're your own worst nightmare
presumably you weren't like this when
you were making one video every day no
okay when did this like kind of
perfectionism develop
well i always want i always want to get
better yeah and so like when you see an
opportunity to get better you take it
yeah and that's what leads you to having
like a lot of things to think about
so like at the point where you decide
okay my face is going to be in a circle
throughout the video yeah then when
you're filming you're aware of that and
then you have to film in a different way
yeah you can't just like avoid your
script
yeah um but if it makes the videos
better you do it yeah yeah it's got to
be done yeah i mean i've i've had the
same philosophy on like i will i will
basically do whatever it takes to make
the video better but i now i am now
seeing just how much more there is to go
in terms of making videos better because
if i if i script for like two hours i
think oh my god this is like a
ridiculously cryptic scripted video
two hours yeah genuinely like my the the
the videos uh
the most scripted video i've done was my
first video that went viral um viral uh
which is on how to study for exams and
that was probably about six hours of
scripting because it was like a
literature review going over the
going on pubmed finding the studies
finding the graphs and then maybe an
extra like 20 hours in the edit to
animate the graphs and stuff for the
first time and i've never put so much
effort into a video since then
um unbelievable
those hours just aren't comprehensible
to me yeah i mean your 100 scripting is
like i'm just thinking oh my god like i
thought i was doing a good job in terms
of trying to
trying to make the videos kind of
i don't take this as me doing a good job
i take this as me not maybe using my
time as efficiently as i should be i i
don't think it's good you know when
you're trying to like build a brand and
stuff yeah and do other things
i think you have to let go a bit i think
you said something to me actually about
if someone else can do the job 80 as
well you should let them
um yeah it's tough for me to get to that
but i can see why yeah
i think
i've i've i've been thinking about that
phrase a lot like
so
when i first made uh well when i did my
first kind of successful business at uni
helping people get into med school i
made the mistake of not delegating
enough and the advice i then came across
a few years later was this thing of if
someone can do the job 80 as well as you
can you should delegate it to them
because your time is worth more you can
do more things and i think when it comes
to growing a business like that that
makes a lot of sense
and i took that advice when it came to
youtube as well because my
my philosophy on this in the past
was
again optimizing for quantity and
recognizing that there is an algorithm
to feed there is a beast to feed
i i kind of felt that
the value for my videos was not in the
edit it was not in a matt davella style
cinematography or peter mckinnon stuff
cinematography or mr who's the boss 2021
style like something happening every one
second it was in
providing somewhat valuable information
and doing it with some kind of like
friendly friendly kind of vibes yeah um
and so that led to
the that uh those axioms led to i think
of okay cool i can then therefore
outsource editing because the editing
it's not that important background music
doesn't really matter we'll just slap
whatever from epidemic sound i've got a
list of kind of songs that i like i
don't like drums cool that could that
creates a vibe
and a few like tweaks here and there
where it meant that i can turn around a
video with
like a lot of our best videos have had
20 minutes of bullet point scripting and
then me just spieling because i'm
usually talking about stuff that i know
sufficiently well if someone asks me
about time management or about
productivity or about personal finance
or money or whatever i can i can just
like talk about it um
and that has gotten us to this point but
there is that thing of what's gotten you
here won't necessarily get you there
and i think when you're when you're
competing in like world-class leagues
the whole 80 delegation thing
i wonder if that stops being effective
i think there's also an element of i
think the reason i don't personally
adopt it
is because
some part of me thinks what's the goal
there yeah it's obviously created with
this idea of like earn the most money
um but that's not really me like i don't
do things to earn money i have enough if
if you enjoy certain parts of the job
and you think you'll have a better
output from it and you'll get better
comments and better engagement yep i
would rather do that even if it earns me
less
yeah
yeah that makes a lot of sense
um
what is your goal for
for youtube these days
i think recently i have started thinking
about things like legacy and like what i
want my brand to mean and things like
that um which is a very
luxurious position to be in
um i think i'm not worried about numbers
or getting more subscribers it would be
great to do that and i'm sure the day
that i hit 10 million is going to be
amazing and i'm going to celebrate and
yeah i'm really looking forward to it
but
um it's a bit bigger than that like i am
thinking about things like books
apps
other things that i want to just try
why
i guess i never would have thought i had
the opportunity to and now that i do
it's
it'll be fun it'd be different
i might be good at it i might really
enjoy it it'll be a new experience if
nothing else so i was gonna ask you this
like how do you think about your brand
career it's like let's say over the next
five to ten years
it's tough you know because like i think
a lot of the growth has happened
recently so i'm still taking in the fact
that i have a large youtube channel now
it's it's new to me so i haven't had
much time to think about these things
but
um
i like to think of myself as a teacher i
think if i had to identify myself as one
thing it would be
someone who educates people
and so
i would like my brand to mean
or be associated with
teacher
okay and so whether that means through
books apps i'm not too sure what the
mechanism is yet
but i have that kind of vision
of like
being i guess synonymous with technology
or education
once you realize that that's what you
wanted to do
very recently okay how did you come to
the realization
i have like a so i've got this new
management team and i think while i'm
kind of stuck in the nitty-gritty
they're very good at sort of seeing the
bigger picture and we have these kind of
weekly calls where they're used to
seeing the journey and the trajectory of
youtubers becoming businesses and so
they
can kind of like impart a bit of that
wisdom or like this is what has worked
for this person this person found this
thing really fun consider it okay and so
i have considered it
so how did that land on teacher
um they asked me at one point like what
what do you see yourself as and it was
then kind of a moment of self-reflection
where i was like okay if you boiled it
down that is what i do i'm trying to
like
make tech fun and you see that as being
like a t-shirt type role
yeah interesting yeah i think like if i
had if i was put into a school and
someone said you have a class to teach
of like 20 kids i think i do a really
good job
um
not saying that that is the job that i
want to do like you know i can obviously
through my camera i can teach millions
um
but that that is actually what i like so
i had a similar a similar realization
about
probably in the last year where i was
trying to answer this question of what
the hell do i want to do with my life
and one of the strategies i came across
was
um
the idea of
asking yourself what do you want written
on your gravestone no
and
i thought i thought about this i was
like okay let's actually take this
seriously what do i want right now
written on my gravestone and i came
very quickly i was like okay some
combination of good father good husband
and inspirational teacher
and i was like oh that's interesting i
hadn't quite realized that because at
the time i was really thinking do i want
to do medicine do i want to do medicine
and then realizing that
if that's what i want written on my
gravestone and we were to work back from
that like
do i care about practicing medicine or
do i care more about teaching it and i
realized that all of the times where
i've had the most fun in hospitals and
at uni has been when i was teaching
other medical students rather than when
i was doing the job
and i was like oh that's interesting
and then
reflecting back on my life again i was
doing like math tutoring when i was like
14 onwards and private tutoring and like
a bunch of teaching in med school and a
bunch of teaching as a doctor and
youtubers teaching has you figured out
um i was like oh this actually you know
that's the thing that gives me
fulfillment therefore let's try and do
more of this stuff and that's actually
changed your whole like approach yeah
because now i'm like great
given that that's like the end goal
to be dead to be dead yeah
to be dead having been a good father
good husband and a good teacher and then
that actually simplifies my life a bit
because now i don't need to be wedded to
uh for example practicing medicine i
don't need to be wedded to for example
um
you know we we've been working with this
business coach which has actually been
been been really helpful trying to
figure out what's what's the core focus
of the business
and um landed on the phrase that
sounds kind of cringe um to help people
live their best life by creating
inspiring educational content
okay and yeah and the more times i say
it the more comfortable i become with
saying it but that that focus kind of
goes with the teaching thing that
ultimately that's what we're trying to
do and it means that like yes it would
be cool to you know we're launching a
stationary line it would be cool to make
my own keyboard it would be cool to have
my own everyday carry bag but that so
those are all side quests and i can
recognize them as being side quests and
it's just it's just a little bit of
spice whereas the core focus the main
thing is is related to teaching
i like the ideology
but i find it hard to
like make my end goal something that
will only happen when i'm not here
anymore
if you see what i mean
this idea of aiming for what's going to
be on your gravestone yeah
it won't matter to you you won't be able
to experience it i think i prefer the
idea of aiming for what do you want your
life to be those kinds of things in 10
years
because that is an end goal that i can
experience ah got it so i i i agree
gravestone stuff you know what are
people gonna say at your funeral that
kind of vibes is all very very very like
long-term thinking
there's another another thing that i've
been using recently more kind of short
to medium term which is uh what does my
ideal ordinary week look like one year
from now five years from now 10 years
from now
and that's a lot more about like
actually i would go on on my calendar
fast forward to you're like 20 26 i'll
be like all right like let's block out
the sorts of things i'd like to be doing
um and through that i realized oh cool i
i like the idea of having one day where
all of my kind of in-person
collaboration with the team is i was
like oh in person great let's build an
in-person team rather than a remote team
i realized that oh i want to be doing
like squash and tennis and badminton
like you know once a week cool let's
block that in blocks of deep work deep
work deep work deep work where the thing
that i enjoy doing is reading writing
and teaching cool let's block that in
deep work oh just like for focus blocks
of work for um
where where i'm not interrupted by calls
and things like that okay um yeah the
book feels high pressure
high pressure yeah like telling myself
that certain amounts of time are going
to be deep work oh it's like
yeah there's a book by cal newport
called deep work which is what what that
reference is where it's basically like
look if you want to do something well
you need to have uninterrupted blocks of
time to do it
um it sounds like your calendar is
fairly deep working by default if you
can have a hundred i think it is i would
say i feel intimidated yeah but if i sat
down and feel like right now to do
something deep work
yeah um how do you think of what you
want your kind of week to look like i'd
say a year from now
the main thing for me is i'd like to
have a little more control over my time
you know this whole fear of like
blocking off days and things i think
that's my one current barrier which i'm
trying to kind of get over
because i have enough as it is i am
happy i'm content like i'm living a good
life
and
i think that kind of fomo i get from
like missing out on potential things
that could be happening it won't really
matter in terms of my end
goal so i just need to get better at
kind of like separating that and then
i'm good being more okay being okay with
like
signing up to a friend's wedding yeah
yeah even if it means saying no to a
helicopter trip
yeah yeah how do you think about money
mostly i use it just for convenience
so like it might mean that i could take
an uber instead of walking or
it just allows you to live your life in
the way that you want to live your life
um
you could order in food one time instead
of like needing to cook yourself those
kinds of things um i don't buy a lot of
possessions i get sent a lot because of
my work but i personally like very
irregularly
because i mean the things that i enjoy
and things that i look forward to are
basically just all experiences like this
weekend is worth more to me than any
like macbook
yeah you know this is this whole idea of
hit on adaptation that once you hit like
whatever whatever you gain you become
accustomed to that thing and then you
are then it you need more of that thing
to to to satisfy yourself
um i find that for me the more money i
make the more the goal post shifts the
more the bar for how much money i need
to be comfortable starts to suddenly
rack up and it's like oh
you know i thought i was actually pretty
happy in a thousand pound a month rental
place but
four thousand a month gets you a really
nice rental place and so i'm not even
gonna really look at what ten thousand
about gets you like that level of stuff
yeah do you do you find yourself doing
that at all um
yeah it's actually like i think about
hedonic adaptation a lot and
i actively try not to do it because i
think it leads you to a life of like
living in a huge house with a enormous
suite of cars
on your own
um feeling like you can't even hang out
with normal people because your life is
so far removed from theirs
that you're different
so i don't think it's a good path to go
down but it's really hard to separate
yourself from it it's like if you could
afford a lamborghini why would you not
buy a lamborghini um those are internal
conversations that i'm sure like most
top youtubers will have with themselves
um but i mean the way i like look at
cars is like okay i'll get a crummy car
and then two years later i'll get a
medium car and then i'll get a slightly
nicer one it's like a nice one like
there's no rush to get to that end goal
and so even if you could theoretically
afford a lamborghini you're like working
up to the buying of a lamborghini
potentially if that's what you're into
yeah rather than just going straight for
it because you can yeah
and i also like the way i see houses is
like a big house you can only be in one
room at any one time right like
i don't like i don't see the point yeah
i quite like the idea of less time spent
hoovering flaws on you know like three
different stories
and more time just doing things i want
to do
i mean the value of a big house is in
being able to host people i think yeah
but then it's very easy to like get an
airbnb and just do the same that's
what's what i'm doing tomorrow oh yeah
and actually that way you can have
different locations every time you have
a party and have more different
experiences do you think about the like
other than the car thing do you think
about the hedonic adaptation in other
aspects of
yeah yeah um i think about it a lot when
it comes to tech
um so i made this video right i'm
worried about humanity and the
underlying theme is that we are choosing
ways of life that are higher stimulation
right yeah
everything around us is becoming higher
stimulation um did you see the meta
facebook rebranding as meta because
they're trying to build a metaverse
okay okay yeah facebook has changed
names to meta right and the idea is
they're trying to build a world where
everyone has
almost a real life experience with
people
from their homes where you can put on
glasses for example connect with people
in a way that you've never connected
before to the point where it's
indistinguishable from actually being
with these people
and the point is we're moving towards
higher and higher levels of stimulation
but hedonic adaptation means that we
will adapt to those levels of
stimulation
and so we won't be happier because of it
but the only thing we will feel is let
down by other people
so the more the stimulation level rises
the more that relative to that the
people around us
fall
is it kind of like when you're used to
listening to things at 2x speed and you
realize people don't talk it to
experience yes and there's a part of you
that feels
like a bit slowly yeah yeah 100 um i
force myself with my friends well with
some of the friends i really care about
to listen at one time speed for that
reason why didn't you move to london uh
i was born in nottingham i've grown up
in nottingham it's like my hometown um
one day i want to move to london but i
want to do it for the right reasons not
because i'm like tied to my friends
because they've got jobs they're busy
it's not like i'm gonna come here and
then all of a sudden my social life's
gonna like rock it forward
i'll do it when it feels right i think
there was something you said in a video
you said uh youtube is a privilege of a
job to have but can also breed an
attitude that creates relentless
unhappiness
what do you what do you mean by that
equating me to myself holding it to
yourself yeah
it's a privilege of a job to have in
that you can work from anywhere and you
can pretty much do anything
and how many people can say that
but but at the same time
it's almost like that whole stimulation
thing the dopamine hit the hedonic
adaptation in that like you very quickly
adjust to that and then you start
thinking about what's next so you become
comfortable with the fact that you have
such a great lifestyle and flexibility
that you do and you start aiming for
higher and higher numbers because it's
so metric driven
it's that idea
and it's a trap that i think most
youtubers at some point fall into and i
think it leads us to making content that
we're not proud of like your clickbait
video
um because you're not even thinking at
that point about viewers you're just
thinking oh i've got to get more
subscribers and the way to get more
subscribers is this this works this is a
data driven yeah i'm just gonna do it
how do you feel when you get a video
that's like tanking
relative to your stuff
that's like 10 out of 10 on that on the
stats like
what what goes through your mind when if
that ever happens
to be honest recently i've been pretty
good at like knowing when a video is not
going to do that well
um i haven't been surprised for a while
actually um i used to be very tied to it
i used to be like it would ruin my day
and i felt only as good as the last
video i'd uploaded that's a youtuber
thing
um
but more and more now i'm pretty much
like i'll post a video and i'm like this
will get a million in the first day this
will get two million in the first i'll
know like roughly there's another thing
i want to quote to you which i thought
was interesting um you said
as as the channel was getting bigger it
felt like this continuous race to remain
relevant among some of the most creative
hardworking people on the planet and
that that really struck home with me
because i i feel this continuous uh
pressure to remain relevant when i was
starting out on youtube it's like you
know i felt like that scrappy startup
you know just just kind of having fun oh
my god oh my god things are working now
that i'm of a reasonable size i am now
the incumbent like the old school boomer
guy who is like struggling i feel
struggling to remain relevant but do you
feel like you're at the top i don't feel
i'm at the top top but i feel i'm sort
of in the
in the major leagues with people who are
in this sort of personal development
type space other than tech there are
very few youtubers who are big today who
were big 10 years ago and all these
thoughts of you know what if my videos
stopped becoming relevant to people what
if no one stopped people stopped caring
what if my whole kind of this internet
career falls down because of the fact
that people stopped watching my stuff
because they no longer identify with
what i say
do you worry about that kind of stuff at
all i think i'm really lucky in the
genre i picked because i think with tech
like by its very nature providing you're
covering the latest tech you are
relevant
um so as long as your videos are
interesting and informative and people
trust your opinion you will continue to
remain relevant
not that i'm taking it for granted but
like i still want to make every video
better than the last but
if the next iphone comes out and i cover
it i think it's it's safe to assume that
people will watch it
yeah like i
i sympathize with gamers you know like
gamers can build up like millions of
subscribers for one game like minecraft
and then when interest with minecraft
falls their entire channel just falls
apart yeah and they have to switch game
and pretty much like start audience from
scratch
that that's horrific yeah yeah that's
really tricky um yeah i guess tech is
one of those nice things where as i i
think you also tech age as well in that
in that as a as a creator
marquez is like more of an authority on
tech than he was 10 years ago whereas in
other things like i started out in the
student market
as a student you are less of an
authority 10 years after graduation than
you were at the point of graduation
where you had all this like wisdom about
what it's like being a student i never
thought of that no you're right you're
right the the ceiling the age ceiling is
very high
yeah i often get messages from wannabe
youtubers like new youtubers starting
out people instagram people take talk
asking
for kind of how
how to become more confident on camera
uh
you come across as very confident on
camera and this is sort of like four
hours of filming if we ignore that side
of things you do seem pretty confident
on camera which strikes me as probably
not how you were when you first started
out
um
what would be your kind of top tips for
someone looking to become more more
camera confident
i think like it's the scariest thing but
you have to just try it
and i think
try it almost ready to receive criticism
and then unmask that criticism into some
useful feedback
so it's like
to to start with like when i first put
my face on i knew that there was going
to be some comments there that i wasn't
excited to read yeah and it was
horrifying that that thought
but i was like well
they'll be usefulness so there were
people like you idiot sit further away
from the camera and if you take away you
idiot that's actually a really useful
piece of feedback um and then i did that
and then it's like get your microphone
out the frame and i'm like okay and then
i research where do you put microphones
oh underneath okay great i'll do that
and slowly but surely you start to move
towards a quality that you're actually
proud of but you've got to accept the
fact that to start with it won't be yeah
because you're watching people who've
been doing it for 10 years for example
yeah a lot of artists talk about this
about how if you're starting out with
drawing
it feels very motivating because you
know what good looks like and you know
that that's not what you're doing
and
um oh the there was this book i was
reading a couple of days ago called uh
the gain and the gap
and how
essentially if you're if you focus on
measuring the gap between where you are
and where you want to be that can be
very demotivating whereas if you focus
on measuring the gain like where have
where are you compared to where you were
you can still keep where you want to be
in mind but you don't fixate on
you don't fixate on the gap i guess like
the the advice i usually give to people
is is also
you will suck at the start and that's
okay
a like no one really cares like it's
it's not the end of the world and you
have to you do have to kind of put in
your reps to get better at the thing
yeah and you put in your rep through
your kind of 300 videos before or kind
of like a video every single day for six
months and once you've put in the reps
and if you're thinking about marginal
improvement over time you just naturally
get very good at doing the thing when
you've been doing it for long enough
yeah and if you feel like you're still
not sure all you need to do is to look
at big creators at the start
providing they haven't deleted their old
videos yeah everyone will have been bad
i think
yeah i think that's oh that's often
quite i s one of the videos we show in
our youtuber course is uh marquez's like
100th video where he's like right video
number 100 yeah yeah i want to want to
give a good shout out to my 74
subscribers
yeah that keeps showing up and i
recommend it yeah it occasionally comes
up
yeah that's quite quite interesting to
see um
this has been fantastic i'd i'd love to
um end with some like a quick fiery type
questions okay so quickfire um what
advice would you give to your younger
self it'll be okay
um who would you say has had the biggest
influence on your career probably
marquez oh how so marquez so mkbhd he
was one of the tech channels i watched
when i was younger and when i was kind
of with my friends and we were talking
about being a youtuber and getting 10
000 subscribers and things like that so
from a very early age i kind of he
provided a framework for what
how it could work what's one tip for
someone who's looking for success start
with something you enjoy
and that you're passionate about and
that you'd want to be the best at what
does the first and last hour of your day
look like so both of them more recently
are without phones
so my entire
waking day is with phones
and the first two are like get out of
bed first
start your day and then turn off
airplane mode
and the last hour of my day is normally
like just lying in a dark room somewhere
oh interesting
okay
it's a thing about sleep like i've had a
lot of problems in the past with sleep
yeah and one of the piece of advice
that's really helped is trying to sync
your life with the real life cycle of
the sun
and that involves the brightness of the
rooms you're in
so i look like a bit of a freak but if
someone calls me for example like when
i'm about to sleep i will just be
sitting in darkness and does that helped
your sleep
nice what material item item under 100
pounds could you not live without
slash has added disproportionate value
to your life it would be under 100
on ebay okay uh the ember mug
oh really so i drink a lot of tea yup
and when i drink my tea i like the
reassurance that it's not going to go
cold
i enjoy it at
62 degrees 52 yeah yeah so um my ember
mug allows me to kind of drink it at
that temperature oh fair play i had an
ember mug for a few weeks and i never
found myself using it it would always
like go cold and there's a wire and like
heating up and well i like i like having
one mug because then it saves washing up
yeah so like every time after i've used
this mug i'll just rinse it there and
then put it to the side
so
that means that there's no loads of mugs
piling up for example so it's a two in
one nice yeah they've recently released
a white one which i was thinking of
getting because it i prefer white vibes
than doctors as well yes
um what book would you recommend to
anyone i actually really enjoyed steve
bartlett's book um
yeah yeah it's good yeah it's very good
if you lost everything let's say youtube
channel's gone um fame has gone money's
gone but you still got all the skills
how would you start from scratch
what would you be doing i think what i
do is like
jump straight back in after my morning
period yeah um i would probably
i mean algorithms now are very favorable
to people who know how to make good
content
so even if you like start a brand new
channel if you make a great video you'll
very quickly be categorized into this
channel makes good videos and so you
have lots of situations where like big
creators will start second channels and
those cycle channels will very quickly
catch up or get a surge in subscribers
because of that
so even though i feel like i've got
loads of capital that i built up it
wouldn't be lost because the main asset
is the skill set what quote or mantra do
you live by i actually don't love quotes
i feel like they sacrifice
practicality for sounding cool a lot of
the time
and finally in journey or destination
journey nice all right aaron thank you
so much for for coming on this has been
an absolute joy it's been amazing i've
learned so much about youtube and stuff
and i feel like i'm now going to go into
a hall and be like oh my god like i need
to
reassess if i thought two hours of
scripting was a long time to spend on a
video needs to reassess either reassess
because 100 is not okay
that's how magic happens you spend an
unreasonable amount of time on on
something that other people wouldn't
wouldn't do and yeah
i'd say that's a big part of why you're
why why you've gone here but yeah thank
you for being so honest thank you for
being so transparent with everything
it's it's been really great
thank you and we'll put links to all of
our stuff in the video description for
whatever that's worth
at your scale but hopefully a little
trickle a little a trickle of people can
confide your channel right that's it for
this week's episode of deep dive thank
you so much for watching i hope you
enjoyed this episode as much as i did
links to all the things we talked about
including aaron's youtube channel and
all the all that jazz will be in the
show notes or in the video description
if you're watching this on youtube and
wherever you're watching this please be
pleased we'd love for you to leave a
review on apple podcasts that's where
the reviews matter even if you don't use
an apple device even if you're not
listening on apple podcasts you will
find a review link in the show notes and
we'd love for you to give the show give
the episode give the the podcast
preferably a five star review and some
comments as well because it helps more
people discover the podcast anyway
thanks so much for listening have a
great evening and i'll see you hopefully
in the next episode bye